ein crash mit der präsidentenlimousine
und das mitten in kiew ukraine ist
präsident vladimir selensky ist in einen
autounfall verwickelt gewesen das hat
sein sprecher bestätigte lenz geht war
in seiner kolonne unterwegs mit seinen
begleitfahrzeuge und dann soll ein auto
in diese kolonne rhein gefahren sein
heute morgen kurz nach mitternacht der
sprecher des ukrainischen präsidenten
bolognese lenski postet auf facebook in
kiew kollidierte ein fahrzeug mit dem
auto des präsidenten der ukraine und
begleitfahrzeugen sanitäter die das
staatsoberhaupt begleiteten versorgten
den fahrer des autos mit nothilfe und
überführten ihn in einen krankenwagen
der präsident wurde von einem arzt
untersucht es wurden keine ernsthaften
verletzungen festgestellt
die behörden werden alle umstände des
unfalls aufklären schrecksekunde für den
präsidenten am tag zuvor war der
ukrainische präsident unerwartet im
osten der ukraine erschienen er besuchte
zum erstaunen vieler einige der unlängst
von den russischen besatzern befreiten
dörfer wie etwa hier easy um selensky
reiste in einem autokonvoi
auch in dem ostukrainischen dorf ballack
lia traf selensky mit ukrainischen
soldaten zusammen auf dem rückweg nach
kiew soll dann der unfall passiert sein
ein unbekanntes fahrzeug soll mit dem
auto des präsidenten zusammengestoßen
sein selensky kommt mit leichten
verletzungen davon nur wenige stunden
später setzt auch er einen post auf
facebook ab den unfall erwähnt er mit
keinem wort gesprochen zwischen unsere
strafverfolgungsbehörden
erhalten bereits beweise für mord folter
und entführungen von menschen durch die
besatzer was die welt in butter gesehen
hat was wir in den nicht besetzten
gebieten von cerny lief und sumi gesehen
haben und was wir jetzt in der region
traf sehen ist der beweis für einen
völkermords an den ukrainern ein beweis
dafür dass russland nicht als völkermord
bringen kann und
in die ukraine zu unserem chefreporter
paul ronzheimer dort bild vize auf
reisen durch die ukraine auch an der
front unterwegs was uns zunächst einmal
über den autounfall reden was weißt du
über die hintergründe dieses crashs vor
allem auch wie geht's denn
ich habe mit dem umfeld von siemens
gesprächen können man sagt der präsident
ist wohlauf man wischt das so ein
bisschen weg was die hintergründe sind
da hält man sich noch in schweigen es
wird ermittelt man muss natürlich auch
immer davon ausgehen das ist einen
versuchten anschlag geben kann geben
könnte auch so lenski darauf gibt es
aber bislang keine hinweise dass muss
man so klar sagen vielleicht ein
hintergrund noch zum präsidenten er ist
ja ins amt gekommen als ehemaliger
komiker als jemand der ein besseres land
einen guten präsidenten gespielt hat und
dieser präsident ist damals immer mit
dem fahrrad in die
präsidentschaftskanzlei gefahren und hat
gesagt er braucht diese großen
autokolonnen nicht mit dem fahrrad
selensky der echte jetzt nicht mehr aber
es ist anders als zum beispiel bei
seinem vorgänger janukowitsch oder auch
bei wladimir putin in russland wo alle
straßen gesperrt werden wenn der
präsident kommt nein das tut er nicht
möglicherweise wird das jetzt bald
passiert
[Musik]